so Tom Voice is a leading expert on the
interplay between neurobiological and
psychosocial processes which leads to
socially partitioned differences in
childhood health development and disease
his work has demonstrated how
psychological stress and neurobiological
reactivity to adverse social contexts
operate conjointly to produce disorders
of both physical and mental health in
childhood populations so thank you Tom
for taking on this task and again
joining us virtually I'll let you go
ahead and I'll come back to the mic to
give you the high sign in terms of time
well hello everybody I'm very sorry that
I can't be there with you physically but
I'm glad the wonders and mysteries of
modern technology I can I can be with
you at least virtually I have chosen as
a title for this chat this afternoon
early adversity in the developing brain
the roles of sensitivity social orders
and schools which I hope will be
especially relevant to those of you in
the education system we have admired for
many years from afar what is going on in
the field of early child development in
Alberta and please take this brief
lecture as a as a commendation for all
of the good work that all of you have
done so if we could go to the next slide
I want to start by just reviewing with
you some of the major events in brain
development I guess I was hoping to do
this sequentially but it looks like I
have all of the red circles up there
just to remind you that there is a an
extraordinary flurry of activity that's
happening biologically and even psycho
socially in the months and years both
before and after birth that begins on
the far left with neural Asian which in
all vertebrate species is the
the beginning of the development of the
central nervous system where the the
neural plate that lies along the back of
the fetus begins to enfold and develops
the the spinal canal and ultimately the
ventricular system of the brain there is
then a period of cell migration from 6
to 24 weeks prenatally in the human
fetus this is a period of time where a
variety of cells are not only
proliferating and replicating but but
moving to different locations that is
optimal for their performance within the
human brain up at the top you can see
that postnatally and and prenatally as
well there is a period of experience
dependent synapse formation at the rate
of during this period 700 new synapses
per second in the developing brain
postnatally and there is also a process
of neurogenesis in the in the
hippocampus of the brain also beginning
very early in those first days and weeks
and months of life is a process of
myelination shown there in the in the
green trajectories this begins at a
great pace immediately prior to birth
and then following birth and actually
extends out on into the years of early
adulthood especially in the case of the
prefrontal cortex which is so crucial in
developing capacities for emotional
regulation and behavior regulation there
are also specializations of the cortex
seeing and hearing develops in those
first few months then there are there is
the acquisition of language and speech
capabilities and then beyond that as the
prefrontal cortex develops in this
myelin myelin a that the development of
higher cognitive functions as well and
all of these happen all of these as you
can see happen
predominantly though not exclusively in
the first
thousand days of life it's not that
there are not significant brain events
in development that are happening beyond
those first thousand days but clearly
there there is a proliferation and a
very special developmental period of
time that is happening over those first
thousand days and those have
implications for life course health and
achievement on into adulthood and really
over the entire life course I could go
onto the next slide this neuronal and
brain circuitry development serves as a
source of great plasticity it is really
the way that these little creatures that
we love and care for so much within our
human societies go from being relatively
rudimentary though elegantly complex
organisms as they emerge from the womb
and develop over our first few months of
life into organisms of extraordinary
capability and and powerful ability you
can see the increasing complexity in the
slides of brain neuron development going
from the newborn period on through 24
months of age and the effect of this is
a powerful cumulative influence of early
experience and exposures on brain
architecture and function you go on to
the next slide the result of this is the
eventual development of an organ that
has 86 billion neurons comprises 85
billion non-neuronal cells 10,000
synapses or connections between neurons
per neuron per each unit of neuron
resulting in a vast circuitry of over a
hundred trillion synapses in the
developed brain and really results in
the development of a the single most
complex physical object in the known
with the number of neurons and
connections far exceeding those of sons
within and stars within the Milky Way on
to the next slide this is really why in
the work of Nobel laureate Jim Heckman
at the University of Chicago he has
shown vividly how those first thousand
days of life and the exposures and
experiences that children have over that
period period of time is really a
sensitive period for intervention
effects and there is actually as
economists talk about at a decreasing
return on investment with increasing age
again it is not that schooling and job
training that happened later in
development are inert or
or insignificant in the developing brain
of a child but you can see that there is
this kind of decreasing rate of return
with the greatest and most critical
exposures in those first few months and
years of life
so all of this points toward the
critical importance of intervening early
on the child's capacity for health and
achievement over the remainder of the
life course so next slide next slide to
summarize then this background material
child development is a critical
foundation for community and economic
prosperity capable children build
successful healthy and sustainable
societies which is what of course we are
all hoping we can build brains are
constructed over developmental time with
the greatest influence during test ation
and over the first three years of
postnatal life brain architecture and
developing abilities are built from the
bottom up
as those simple circuits scaffold more
advanced circuits and skills
creating the right conditions for
childhood development and health is more
effective and less costly than
addressing problems at a later stage in
childhood or in adulthood and finally
regrettably those right conditions exist
really for only a subset of the world's
children as well as for a subset of
North American children now why that is
the case if we go on to the next slide
look up on the northwest side of this
slide physical and mental health are
highly layered or partitioned by
socioeconomic status is showing
socioeconomic status going from the
lowest to the highest going left to
right and on the vertical axis the
percentage of children with a variety of
chronic pediatric conditions including
ear disease physical inactivity asthma
and injury this is equally true of
academic achievement so the northeast
side of the slide shows socioeconomic
background SES on the horizontal axis
and on the vertical axis reading
performance on a standardized
achievement tests and again you can see
that while the the slope for different
countries may vary there is still this
monotonic linear association with
children of higher SES backgrounds
having greater meeting performance over
time now these differences can be
attributable to a whole variety of
explanatory exposures many of which I am
sure come immediately to mind as you
think about these linear this linear
gradient of health and development
differential exposures to toxins
differences in diet differences in
access to healthcare housing differences
exposures to violence differences in
parenting skills and abilities but also
differences in exposure to adversity and
stress which we think are is one of them
the major mediators of this linkage
between socioeconomic status on the one
hand and health and development on the
other and it is this adversity and
stress as mediators that I want to focus
your attention on today for the
remainder of my talk next slide shows
the socio-economic partitioning of
stressors and adversity among children
growing up in poverty versus those
growing up in middle income communities
and you can see that in the case of the
density of housing other housing
problems noise and the ambient
environment family turmoil and exposures
to violence both within the family and
within the neighborhood and community
that children in impoverished
circumstances have far greater exposures
to these stressors and adversities than
do children from more advantaged
communities next slide
this shows the sequela at the neuronal
level of these kind of early stress
exposures in animal models the control
animals neuron is on the left the early
expressed animals on the right and what
you can easily see is a diminished and
simplified dendritic branching though
the branches of the tree if you will of
the neuron the decrease in dendritic
spine density and the spring edge
overall of a neuronal cell body you
don't need to be a neuroscientist to
look at these two neurons and see that
the one on the right is severely
diminished relative to the complexity of
the one on the left tom four minutes
left okay
[Music]
let's skip to to the twelfth slide nope
next one so two findings that I'd like
to share from recent research the first
is that there is tremendous individual
variation in neurobiological
susceptibility to stressors and
adversity second is that there are
health effects of social position in
early peer hierarchies that we see
within with old micro societies of
schoolchildren the next slide shows all
at once two different versions of this
socio-economic gradient of socioeconomic
status predicting reading performance
the one on the Left shows the on the top
shows the summary that I showed you
before of gradients in reading
performance by SES the one on the right
shows Canadian children and shows the
actual data ones and the point here is
that there is a tremendous diversity
underline these linear regression line
associations you can see that it looks
like a shotgun the screen of that
association there's a tremendous amount
of variation the same if you look on the
bottom is true of exposures to adverse
childhood events there is a nice linear
gradient shown on the left but when you
look at the actual data points there's a
tremendous diversity of response to
these kinds of adverse events the next
slide shows that how because of this
extraordinary variability in response to
adversity and stress we began years ago
bringing children into laboratories
where we put them in front of a
previously unknown examiner had them go
through a series of mildly stressful
tasks and while we were doing that
tapped into the two major stress
response systems within the human brain
the hypothalamic pituitary adrenal
cortical system chemin purple which is
the cortisol system and the locus
coeruleus norepinephrine autonomic
system which is shown in blue and that
is the system which ignites the entire
fight-or-flight response and slide one
more minute tongue well then let's go to
the 20-second slide this is the slide
that is labeled the crux of the argument
okay so I'm gonna skip all the data and
just tell you what I was planning to
tell you here are the three points that
I hope I can leave you with I'm sorry
that I don't have the time to actually
show you the research that lies behind
the findings but but here they are the
first is that exposures to stress and
adversity in early life can have
powerful enduring influences on the
developing brain on the capacities for
learning and academic achievement on
vulnerability to mental and physical
disorders and on lifelong health and
well-being
these early major influences on the
developing brain are really what sculpts
our entire society and its capacities
for flexibility for creativity and for
learning the second point is that there
are broad substantial individual
differences in children's susceptibility
to adversity with a subset of children
that show heightened sensitivity to both
adversity and to supportive social
environments so there are these children
who have heightened sensitivity to
social environments both positive and
negative and these are children that I
think we need to be particularly aware
of and sensitive to in the developing of
educational systems in the way we're in
and so on third and final point is that
paralleling the social partitioning of
health in human adult societies children
occupying subordinate lower positions in
their peer hierarchies that evolve and
develop within the classrooms of young
children sustain disproportionate rates
of mental and physical health symptoms
which can be ameliorated by teachers use
of more egalitarian pedagogical
practices kids as young as two three
four five develop pecking orders of
dominance hierarchies and preschool and
primary school teachers can do much to
ameliorate the health and developmental
effects
of subordinate positions within those
hierarchies and I think I've even over
my last minute Tom I just want to thank
you so much for that presentation but
also your flexibility I know there are
likely many people who have many
questions for you now so I think we just
have a couple of minutes before the next
presenter for any questions in the room
or if those online would like to send in
their their questions as well that's an
opportunity to put those forward so
please show your hand if you'd like to
ask a question we'll get a mic to you
right away so Tom you may have another
minute here if there are no questions
okay thank you
just taking the mic to someone who will
be with you just a sec hi there I was
wondering if you found any common
factors among those who were highly
sensitive to their environment did you
do any further research were there
biological factors that were common
among those those kids
I lost the last part of your question
whether were there common features to
those kids yeah who are highly sensitive
to their environment you know what I
didn't what I didn't get to show you at
all is the fact that in these laboratory
experiments that we did with children
those who were highly sensitive to their
environment responded in these to stress
response systems with heightened
reactivity biologically in the way that
they responded to these challenging
tasks that we put before them these are
kids who tend to be in general Shire
children they are more behaviorally
inhibited they withdraw from novel
experiences but they are children who
actually do beautifully and thrive
remarkably in environments where they
are supported where things are
predictable
where they are encouraged and and
supported in a variety of different ways
so they are children who have either the
worst outcomes or the best outcomes
depending upon the character of the of
the social setting that they are being
reared and be that a family or an
educational system or a peer hierarchy
or or whatever thank you
any other questions
go ahead they're bringing a mic over to
you Thank You Thomas my question is the
other end of the spectrum and so you've
shared with us your observations about
hypersensitive children what about the
children in that environment who despite
the adversity may have done better and
more effect and cope more effectively
than others what could you tell us that
the dad has said about them yeah these
are actually the majority of children in
our research you know we we talk and
think about resilience as something that
is sequestered in a little sub
population of children we think of
resilient children as being those who in
the face of inordinate adversity seem to
thrive and there definitely are those
children but what our research seems to
indicate is that the majority of
children in our in our samples eighty to
eighty-five percent of children who are
experiencing these mildly stressful
challenges that we put to them in the
lab they do just fine and they and they
they are lower in biological reactivity
to the to the social environment and in
real life under normative conditions of
a challenge and sort of species typical
adversity these are kids who do very
well we call them our dandelion children
after a Swedish term not crows barn
which means dandelion child and what the
Swedes mean by that is that there is
this group of children who like the
dandelion can thrive in almost any
environment
which they are planted thank you very
much for that thank you for that
we'll now move on to then oh we don't
have time for more questions now that
I'd please ask you to and they'll take
the online question at the end of all of
the speakers so we'll have a chance to
have more conversation once all of the
panelists are finished